Nhà tiền tiền được xanh nhưng hàn ỏ lai, tân sốt công nghệ, ngoả tiền trường bất động sản.
Chỉ với mức buổi like chim, các nổ tiền tiền sẽ đời có thể được chút đơn nghề trên sống mắt sạ hội,
sấm như việc mua bổ bổ mổ đổ or lai, dựa thân sấu, phân nhân quyết của cường đã rejuí,
khi cũng được tắt tổ chức like chim bản hương bụng nghiêm các nổ tại vì dương,
nãy thuộc phở biên ngoà thành phố Chỉ Minh, với mức sạ tự bá bế bá trực đồng trên mục đếp vông,
phải im đại like phải cố định năm 2019.
Một trăm trong lâm năm, mối phát sống này, khi nhận tới một chấp năm 2019,
một dinh hai trong khách để lại thông tin và năm 2019, không dừng lại ở đó,
sẵn sài ghl quốc nhé trong nhé của bối truổi phía trợ bất động sản chực tiền.
Ngay mong tạm trong bệnh, mục cân hộ bệnh, mấy bà mết vông tại hà lối,
lửa chốt bây giờ bây giờ phía năm 2019, hơn một chăm lệ 2 chậu đồng trên mục mếp vông,
sau khi chủ đầu tư giảm tế, năm 2014 cho khách mổ qua like chim,
sẵn sài cho biết sẽ tiếp tục bán các sân phẩm thấp tân vệ giả tư sau phía tạm tìm đồng bán hiếm tức này.
Tìm nhìn kích trên ra chức rằng đây với chỉ là công cộng quốc quốc đặc trên thông,
hơn là suốt sâu sây thức xử, ông điên mình đón bất động sản chăm công trên biên nhận định.
Lại chim chủ yếu xúc tú đủ thế hành trẻ, con nó phạm được tỏan,
í dí phần rục bất tiền, nhưng mấy mù nhà vẫn cần tận mắt kìm chá dự án pháp li fact rất lợt trước khi xuống tiền.
Lều lại chim bán các tộc sản của tức xử trở thành của bí mạng mô nhà thời bún trập không,
hãy chỉ là chiều tức mà cái tình grey xuất tạm thơi.